[Applause]
that's from mrs. files no that's not the
sound of cats in distress that's the
sound of one super shook Harry Styles
fan that's from mr. spies here's what
went down on Wednesday Harry stopped by
The Today Show where he performed
outside in the rain
enter marry a Harry Styles superfan who
was there to watch the former One
Direction er sing rain or shine well
here he noticed Mary crying in the crowd
during his soundcheck and asked Carson
Daly to go over and give her some VIP
tickets to his upcoming tour now let me
warn you guys it's about to get real
dramatic in here Mary we noticed during
sound check we noticed there [ __ ] you
were crying
Harry noticed that you were crying he's
going on tour this summer and he'd like
to give you VIP tickets
okay guys she literally fell to the
ground
drama is at a ten out of ten and I'm
here for it not kidding
that's from mrs. files Mary we love you
girl but only dogs can hear you now
that's so the best part of this whole
thing though is Mary's friends we don't
want you we love you thank you for
costume enjoy the show
breathe breathe no no her friend
literally can't but we can here to
reenact this dramatic scene et Digital
zone for I Bennett's playing the role of
Mary Mary yours truly as the mortified
bestie scene one take one mark action I
drop me anyway Harry super fan Mary is
giving Harry super fan lizzo a run for
her money the two gave us major
friendship goals at the 2020 Brit Awards
holding hands resting their heads on
each other's shoulders I mean she even
kissed his hand what is this apple juice
oh my god that's to get out okay thank
you very much literally meet tequila
he's gone off the rails I can't join us
after the break when we're they
seriously Liz oh nice that's neat
tequila oh my god
[Applause]
okay oh yeah then there's that Liz OH
finishing off Harry's tequila
[Music]
back in December Harry took the mic in
BBC Radio One's Live Lounge in London
and ladle is OHS hit track juice then
lizzo covered harry song adore you in
February
[Music]
so who's the bigger hairy fan Liz Oh
[Music]
Mary
that's from mrs. files tough call of
course you can count on et to bring you
all the latest on Harry Styles so make
sure to keep it locked right here until
next time I'm Hallie Stevens see you
soon and Mary stay strong
[Music]